a Great British Bake Off star Dame Prue
lease is a passionate advocate for
assisted dying which at the moment
remains illegal in Britain her son the
conservative MP Danny Krueger completely
disagrees he spoke out recently in
parliament against assisted dying in a
debate which was held after a petition
reached a hundred thousand signatures
over half the people in other countries
were assisted dying as legal choose it
because they feel they're a burden to
their families surgically also say they
are lonely isn't this terrible people
getting the state to help to kill them
because they don't want to be a burden
on a family that never visits them
talk to any hospice manager about
relatives and they will quietly confirm
it there are a lot of people who want
granny or Grandpa to hurry up and die
well here we have a very famous mother
and her nearly as famous political son
loggerheads on a fascinating debate but
I spoke to Dame prilith a little earlier
about this
well I'm joined Now by Prue Leaf pru
lovely to talk to you
hello Pierce this is a very serious
subject and opinions have been raging on
both sides about it why do you feel so
passionately about this issue
well I suppose it's because I'm 82 and
heading for the big decision
um but
I I really I mean I I started getting
interested in the whole subject when my
um elder brother died and he died a a
really horrible death
um
and recently my younger brother died and
he died at home with his family around
him and
he didn't have assisted suicide because
he didn't need it but he had the sort of
death that I think that people who want
assisted with suicide
um would dearly love to have you know at
home their own bed surrounded by their
family what's very interesting Pro is
that in many states in America including
California and New Jersey Washington
Vermont
um in many of the states assisted
suicide is completely legal it's legal
in many parts of Australia uh it's legal
I think in Canada now so there are lots
of countries in the world where assisted
suicide is now a legal practice
what's more it's being
um you know it looks as if um as if
Jersey
um Scotland will get there before us I
mean it's it's only the the UK
government that has been so delicious to
play devil's advocate for a moment there
are reports out of Oregon for example uh
where 53 percent of patients who were
helped to die gave us a reason that they
were a burden on family friends and
carers rather than citing pain or fear
of pain are you concerned about about
that part of it
yes um I think that first of all I think
it's a legitimate reason
um if you you know if you know that you
are causing your your family a lot of
anxiety and anxiousness and and and and
worry about you and you are
um either in huge pain or not enjoying
your life then
um it's it it's a valid reason I mean
I'm not saying for a minute that
um
that people should
want to commit suicide or have an
assisted death
just because they're about
but being a burden is one of the things
that that is so distressing I mean see
this is where I think the the slippery
slope argument which I think Gordon
Brown and others have espoused I do
think there is a concern there isn't it
where you you know you're you're from a
lovely family of well-intentioned people
I have no doubt
um however there are lots of families
which perhaps are not quite so well
intentioned to their oldest and not so
dearest
um who particularly there's money
perhaps lurking in wills and so on would
be tempted potentially to really make
these people feel they are a massive
burden and should Shuffle off this
Mortal coil very sharp-ish
yeah I mean that that is a really
serious worry I mean first of all I
think we have to have enough safeguards
to be absolutely certain that this is
the patient or the person's real choice
and that they're not being um in any way
coerced and there are ways to do that
but it does require you know a lot of
interviews and and and care but also I
think I really think this is a bit of a
bogeyman that doesn't although it does
exist it is quite small one of your sons
he's a Tory MP who's actually vehemently
opposed this legislation so what are you
going to do if you decide in a few years
time you've become a massive burden and
he says sorry sorry mum I'm not doing it
well I'm that's going to be a real
problem because we are devoted to each
other
um and he has generally very um
principled
um objections I think he's quite wrong
um but I hope you'll I'm hoping I've
managed to first of all I'm hoping that
he will not manage to master all his
mates in Parliament to vote against it
and that I will manage to persuade him
before I get there I mean it's a
fascinating situation where your own son
is literally in the house of the
parliament campaigning for the complete
opposite many families have
disagreements about all sorts of things
we happen to have I want about this what
I really think I honestly believe that
it I should be
um in control of my own life I mean I
think the idea that
um that that somehow human life is is so
sacred I mean sacred to whom it's not
sacred to me and it's my life okay so
here's again
I get it but here's the thing if I talk
to your son about this I'm sure he'd say
well that's fine that might be her view
my mother's view but actually I love my
mother and I don't want to lose my
mother and I want to get every moment I
can out of her and if she's not in
searing Agony but it's simply drifting
towards the end of her life I don't want
her to be to be pulling the plug yes we
would only be having this conversation
when I was within six months of dying I
don't believe that my son would ruin
make my last six months even more
distressing by
um by refusing me that I think he would
argue a lot of those people I don't want
to speak for him but he I think from the
arguments he's put forward he would
probably argue to that point he would
say that you're doing your decision
would compound his distress what about
his right to not let you take your life
no I'm sorry when it comes to my own
life it's my life
he's going to have he's going to lose me
within six months anyway so you know man
up and bear us a few months earlier
really it's a fascinating debate uh not
least your own situation with your own
family uh but unfortunately you're
looking in rude health so we won't have
to encounter this issue I would imagine
for a very long time to come thankfully
but thank you for joining me I
appreciate it there are so many people
who are not in mood health and we need
to think about them yeah we do it's a
it's an interesting debate and as you
say most of the public are with you not
your son
yeah
it's great to talk to you bye-bye